what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the ultimate X-Men by the
way remember tomorrow we're covering
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four but
the name changes to Future Foundation
just be aware of that so getting into
ultimate X-Men are really kind of
finishing this first volume that we
started a couple weeks ago this
basically brings in Wolverine now
Ultimate Universe Wolverine is starkly
different than the main Marvel Universe
Wolverine in a lot of different ways
there's similarities but there's also a
lot of differences here so one of the
things that happens and one of the
things you remember from the last video
that we did is that Magneto contacted
Wolverine for the purpose of basically
getting in and finding a way to kill
Charles Xavier and so once Wolverine
basically emerges from the airport which
the questions asked how in the world did
you manage to get through an airport
without setting off like metal detectors
or anything like that it's the usual
response that Marvel Comics gives us
just kind of a hand wavy explanation why
you gotta know a guy you know that kind
of a thing right mobile just usually
Dodges that all the time but once he's
out here we end up finding out that he's
immediately attacked by what's basically
the federal government and then subdued
right like literally Wolverine seems to
die right off the bat or at least is
captured right off the bat now that's
when we switch over to the ultimate
X-Men and of course Xavier calls the
team together and says okay we have
another mutant signature that exists out
there I need all of you to meet me in
the danger room because this one is a
really significant moment and that's
when he reveals to the team Wolverine is
basically in our general vicinity like
Wolverine has resurfaced and he's
effectively been captured now the
response of the X-Men here kind of comes
in two parts the ones who have been
around the block a few times are scared
out of their wits the ones who are new
here don't know anything and they're
more Curious than anything else what
Marvel establishes here and this is
where things get a little interesting
and you really kind of deviate away from
the normal main Marvel Universe when it
comes to how Wolverines handled that
Wolverine here in the Ultimate Universe
is literally the world's deadliest man
like he's the deadliest assassin that
exists in the world now there is a lot
of history there but the history of
Wolverine here is wildly different than
the his history of Wolverine in the main
Marvel Universe and honestly when
Wolverines introduced to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this is the way in
which it'll be done the origin story in
the ultimate universe that's how it'll
happen now if you are curious about that
once we're done with this video I
believe I have a video on the ultimate
origin of Wolverine that's already been
done so you're welcome to check that out
once this video is finished I'll have a
link to it down in the description and
we'll post a link to it at the end of
the video but still it's a pretty cool
story right but the thing about this is
that Wolverine was actually captured by
what was basically Weapon X right
weapons plus if you want to call it that
now again this is where things differ in
the main Marvel Universe Wolverine and
Weapon X they do have a bit of a sketchy
history and so far it's like Wolverine's
not the closest and the best of friends
with like Maverick or Sabretooth or
silver fox or any of those guys but the
fact that they serve so long as a team
allows them to kind of call in favors
with the other if they ever really need
it here in the Ultimate Universe there's
a dark history here and while we don't
necessarily get the nitty-gritty of it
here in this particular Story one of the
things that we do learn is that
Wolverine was really more of kind of an
inexpendable asset for Weapon X in the
sense they would just send them into
missions where where men would normally
be killed they'd have Wolverine do his
duty and then they would bring him back
but they would also torment and torture
him right like he you know one of the
things that said by wraith is how much
fun they used to have with his healing
Factor right like setting him on fire or
different things like that just to see
how things happened like it was very
much a terrible situation for the
character of Wolverine and that's one of
the reasons why he became the person
that he was now again Wolverine's origin
in the Ultimate Universe is actually
closely intertwined with the origin of
Captain America Steve Rogers and really
more Nick Fury than anything else right
like Samuel Jackson Nick Fury it's
pretty cool it's a pretty cool origin
story and I think it's probably one of
the better origin stories for his
character but of course the X-Men
basically respond as you expect them to
they show up here on the scene and they
are basically able to free Wolverine
from Weapon X and they ultimately bring
Wolverine in onto the team and then
bring him back to the Xavier Institute
now this is the beauty of the situation
right because at that point we
transitioned to Magneto and what Magneto
reveals is this is all part of the plan
right this was literally all part of the
plan the goal of Wolverine right the the
whole idea what happened here Wolverine
basically resurfaces he's like the
government's tipped off to the location
of Wolverine Wolverines captured
Wolverines basically held for a little
while the X-Men will ultimately end up
saving him right because you know the
X-Men saved mutants and they're good
guys and so on and so forth right so
they're highly predictable and in doing
so because they don't really know the
actual mission of Wolverine and because
they are a humanitarian group insofar as
how they deal with like mutant relations
they would bring Wolverine into the team
so it's literally just a giant Trojan
Horse and it's a genius idea now the
other part of this and what makes things
so wild is that once Wolverine is here
initially Jean Gray rebukes him but it's
one of those things where she does it
because in reality she doesn't want to
come off too easy right that's kind of
how that is in the Ultimate Universe and
it's one of those weird things Wolverine
and Jean Gray end up do having a
relationship right and we'll talk about
that here in a minute because it does
happen in this story you know they
basically end up banging but of course
there's the kind of Grudge that takes
place between Wolverine and cyclops and
so what you end up getting is really
Gene gray who kind of looks at uh looks
at Wolverine with a bit of interest
because he's the bad boy right like
Cyclops is the good guy he's predictable
right he is as predictable as the sun
rises and in time that will be the thing
that like Jean Greg will become
interested in right because the the lack
of certainty and the lack of stability
and this whole thing of like I don't
know what tomorrow brings that only
lasts for a little while then it gets
old right because then you want
something reliable you want someone
reliable and so ultimately what would
end up happening here is that with Gene
with Jean Gray and Wolverine she's very
very smitten she's very very interested
in him and basically the two of them end
up banging right like literally they
just end up banging like he just runs up
on her just gives her a kiss that kind
of a thing because he's one of those
guys where he's like it's you know like
I'm not the guy you say no to right and
that kind of thing is what really really
attracts her right the good girl who
loves the bad boy that's really all it
is but the crazy thing about all this is
that while that whole romantic kind of
fling and everything's going on well
there's a lot of flirting going on
between the two of them before anything
serious happens that Magneto makes his
move and literally kidnaps the
president's daughter right like just
kidnaps this girl and holds her Ransom
right and literally just like makes this
declaration to like the World At Large
that like I have the president's
daughter right like you will cease and
desist any actions against the mutant
population hunting us down different
things like that or I will take your
daughter out right like I mean not on a
date either like I'm gonna like you know
I'm gonna help her finish with all of
her living right if you understand what
I'm saying like that's basically what
that means and so it's one of those
things where it really is a dangerous
Gambit because it could go either way on
one hand the president could double down
and say okay we're gonna come after you
harder than they were before but the
reality here is the president is a
family man right like it's his daughter
and so in a lot of ways as you would
expect with a traditional fictional
story like this the president ultimately
backstage now but in doing so it
emboldens Magneto and so what ends up
happening here is you basically have a
mission organized by the X-Men which are
sent to what's basically Croatia where
the daughter of the president's being
held in order to find her to free her
and to bring her to effectively safety
right like to literally save her life
for the most part it happens right not
all the X-Men really go on or at least
you know save the president's daughter
some basically stay here and end up
dealing with like Magneto and and so on
and so forth and it kind of goes you
know in terms of it being a bit of a
fight it is cool right because you do
remember have characters like storm and
so on who are the new people here right
I mean remember in the last video that
we covered storm is new to her powers
she doesn't know exactly how her
abilities work so she's figuring it out
as it goes along it's not like the main
Marvel Universe where she was brought in
by Professor Xavier with just total
control over her abilities even on the
most nuanced levels she's literally just
discovered them not only that of course
you do also have Cyclops Behind Enemy
Lines you've got all these guys here who
are are doing what they can to hold
their own against the forces of Magneto
and the funny thing is that once the
daughter is often safe right like
literally Wolverine saves her life takes
off that's basically it the rest of the
X-Men actually starts talking to Magneto
to kind of find out what it is that he's
even going for here right like what were
you hoping to really achieve by
kidnapping the president's daughter
Because unless you were going to hold on
to her forever right unless like you
were just gonna keep her in a bunker for
the rest of her life you know there's
only so much that's actually going to
come out of this and even then like once
that president leaves office a new
president is going to come in and he
doesn't much care about the other
president's daughter right so literally
this plan you have is only going to last
however long the president's term lasts
and then it's going to be online Donkey
Kong right like that's literally what
it's going to be so this is kind of a
stupid maneuver but the reality here for
Magneto is it was more of a show of
force it was more of showing Humanity
that even their most highest ranking
officials right the president of the
United States a man who is believed to
be Untouchable is not untouchable that
mutants can get to humanity just as
easily as Humanity can get to mutants
they simply just choose not to and so as
a result of that it's really more him
just kind of being like either you can
play ball with us right like you as the
X-Men you can play ball on our side or
you will be our enemy you will get
caught in the crossfire and I will
inevitably destroy you right so it's
really more just kind of a warning hence
the reason why he lets them leave but
once you switch back to basically Beast
of course who had been injured in the
process this is one of the interesting
things about his character because he
had been injured and there wasn't in
really kind of an easy way to cure him
there is talk about a cure that exists
out there in the world but there have
basically been you know instances
whereby those individuals who have been
cured using this particular process end
up developing blue fur right or like
blue hair or something like that so it's
just kind of the Ultimate Universe way
of being like this is how Hank McCoy
becomes the big furry blue guy that you
all love right you know that kind of a
thing but it's still cool because again
you basically switch over to Jean Gray
and and Wolverine and literally really
like what range is straight up a
straight up ass or he's like how do you
feel about me Gene and she's like
honestly I'm not sure I particularly
like you Wolverine right like sure
you've proved yourself as an X-Man but I
haven't bought this idea that you're an
overnight convert to Professor Xavier's
like you know integration ideology right
like you're you're not one of us right
like you're not a good guy you're really
not for the cause she's like your weapon
x training might mean that I can't read
the thoughts that you don't want me to
but I'm empathetic enough to know that
you're here for all the wrong reasons I
think the way people have treated you
over the years has really screwed you up
and as much as it goes against
everything the school's supposed to
stand for I really really wish I'd never
met you and so that's when he asked the
question then why do you find me so
attractive and her response is I wish I
knew and literally guy just lays the
kiss on her and cyclops is just watching
it all happen right like ever the [ __ ]
Cyclops is just watching the girl he
likes basically get banged by somebody
else see this this is one of the things
about this right because like in
response to that instead of Cyclops like
nutting up and just be like okay so
here's the deal Gene that guy's a dick
right and like you don't need that guy
he's a terrible dude I'm better than he
is right like I'm the guy you should be
going after right like let's make
something happen here like fighting for
what he wants right like in the end he's
just like I'm Gonna Leave the team you
know and it's just like okay like come
on man like that that's your response
right this guy comes out of nowhere
snatches up the girl that you like and
and your response is to quit like no
wonder you're gonna lose that girl man
like there are some things in this world
that if you wanted you're gonna have to
learn to fight for it now not every
girl's worth fighting for but like that
one is
so you should go fight for that one you
know and that's it's one of those crazy
things right and so ultimately basically
Cyclops ends up meeting with Xavier and
it's just like I don't believe in the
Stream that you have anymore right like
Magneto's response kind of resonated
with me and I believe what it was
Magneto had to say so I'm basically
leaving like literally he takes off now
in reality here that's all a show I mean
the truth of the reason why Cyclops was
leaving is because the girl he likes is
banging another dude and he just can't
handle it right and so he ultimately
ultimately ends up taking off and
basically joining Magneto's side now
that's where things get really cool
because at this point what we end up
doing is basically picking up with like
the first real mission that is launched
with Cyclops and really uh Magneto's
Brotherhood and so on and even with the
X-Men basically being called together by
uh by Professor X now one of the things
that goes on is like wolverines like
okay so like what's what's the deal you
know like what's what's going on and
Gene's like well the professor needs us
and he's like okay well like we'll get
to it like 20 minutes right and the two
of them go back to banging again right
it's just it's it is weird because
technically Gene I think because like 19
and wolf range like 40 right it's just
it's kind of a strange situation but the
reality here is that Professor Xavier
called the X-Men together because the
president requested the presence of uh
of Magneto and what the president had
learned is that Magneto is based in the
Savage land right like literally a
jungle in Antarctica that has like
dinosaurs and all that kind of stuff I
know the ultimate universe is supposed
to be rooted in the real world go with
it it's a comic book it's not supposed
to be 100 real just have fun with it
right who cares but the thing about this
is that the response of the president is
like look this guy kidnapped my daughter
and I can't let that go so we're
launching a full-on strike against
Magneto like we're basically deploying
all the Sentinels we have at our
disposal and we're sending them there
and we're going to basically annihilate
the entirety of Magneto's forces because
we have to show not only the American
people but we have to show the world the
United States will not stand for this
this level of intolerance now the truth
about this and what's so interesting is
it really is the human race creating its
own problem them and then trying to
eliminate the problem that it created
right like mutants just existed I mean
it's not like mutants were just running
around just trying to eradicate the
whole of humanity they simply just
existed the response of the human race
was to annihilate mutants out of fear or
to capture them and kill them whatever
the case happens to be which is what led
to a guy like Magneto in the first place
and so it's kind of nuts because what
you end up getting is literally the
entirety of the Sentinel really Army
just showing up at the Savage land and
then Magneto literally scoffs and you
would expect him to right he's like
really like humanity is going to send an
army of metal robots against the master
of magnetism right if this is not a
full-on depiction of humanity stupidity
I really don't know what is how dumb
would you have to be to sit an army of
metal robots against a guy who can
control metal like Humanity's got to be
the stupidest organism on the entirety
of the earth it's a good thing I'm gonna
wipe them all out right like it's just
it's like I'm doing you a favor by
putting you out of your misery because
you're all too stupid to keep living
that's literally Magneto's response here
right like this is you guys are dumb you
know it's it's just it's a laughable
situation and so not only do these
Sentinels come arriving here once they
do Magneto doesn't immediately destroy
them instead he uses his powers over
magnetism and just his incredible amount
of knowledge on computers and all that
kind of stuff to literally rewire the
entirety of the Sentinels to basically
reprogram them and then turn them to his
side so the army of humanity just became
the army of Magneto and that's the thing
like Humanity developed an army that was
capable of destroying mutants imagine
what this Army could do if it was turned
on humans who don't have powers who
don't have abilities right and so what
ends up happening here is we end up
finding out that where Wolverine had
joined the X-Men as basically a plant by
Magneto that Cyclops is on Magneto's
team as a plant for Xavier like
literally when all this is popping off
Cyclops is like Professor X this is
Cyclops we have a situation here sir
like it was it was basically a move
right now at that same time we jump back
to Jean Gray and Wolverine literally
Wolverine reveals to Jean Gray that he
was here to kill the Professor X right
now Jean Gray of course freaks out
because she's just like like she just
starts screaming at him and cussing at
him but the whole reason why Wolverine
did this and the argument he creates is
like meeting you and being with you has
basically changed my mind this story is
written by Mark Miller so it's one of
those Mark miller-esque things where
he's just like we need a reason for
Wolverine to basically turn code I don't
know Jean Gray was really good in bed so
like that's reason enough and like
that's that's really all you get right
but it's basically him just joining the
side of the X-Men now of course with
with Wolverine on the side of the X-Men
cyclops within the mutant Brotherhood
and on the side of uh of of Magneto or
at least on the side of Xavier within
Magneto's ranks that is one of those
things where he actually takes
Quicksilver aside now the cool thing
about this and this is one of the most
significant moments Quicksilver is the
Sun that had always been overlooked by
Magneto and in a lot of ways had always
just kind of been talked down to right
Mike you don't never really took him
seriously he's just kind of like you're
incompetent you always get things wrong
yada yada but basically setting the
stage for Quicksilver to effectively
turn against his father and to walk away
and so once this like conflict begins
right like these Sentinels like the
X-Men show up this Sentinel start
attacking the X-Men the X-Men start
attacking the Sentinels this massive
battle unfolds between like both teams
that it is cool to see some of this
stuff happen right you have storm who's
getting a better understanding of her
abilities so being able to destroy
Sentinels using lightning and so on is
working pretty well but Magneto has
basically launched his attack against
the president of the United States right
going after the White House Magneto
shows up here and literally has the
president just cowering in fear naked on
the ground right and that's literally
when he's just like listen carefully
Homo sapiens this is like one of the
best speeches ever right he says because
I will say this only once your reign as
Earth's dominant species is formerly at
an end the creature you regard as the
most powerful man has just cleaned my
boots right his execution now will serve
as a warning to other world leaders who
refuse to recognize the new position in
the coming Global Order right he says
obey us and you may live as our slaves
and play things disobey and you will be
categorized as mutant foodstuffs America
dies tonight at the age of
225. your intolerance and all-consuming
greed will not be missed and that's the
crazy thing is this because you know the
the United States in the eyes of a lot
of other nations around the world within
the Ultimate Universe is looked at is
like kind of like D major player so it's
the smartest move of Magneto to launch a
strike against the United States so
literally What's it gonna be right like
because I've I've I'm taking over this
place what's gonna happen now now at
that moment it basically leads to
Professor Xavier making his move there
is a bit of a fight between like Magneto
and Professor X it is kind of I mean
it's not funny but it's a little bit
funny because I'm needle just like
knocks him out of his wheelchair and
he's just like I've had enough of you
old man like it's one of those things I
mean it's not something that would be
funny if you saw it in real life but
it's funny as hell here you know it's
one of those things that's kind of
messed up but still like it's one of
those instances where for the most part
they're really kind of powerless in the
face of Magneto because this is a guy
who can control virtually every form of
metal that exists in the world and he
can manipulate the electromagnetic
spectrum now one of the big differences
here is that Magneto in the The Ultimate
Universe is not as powerful as he is in
the main Marvel Universe however there
are things that he does in the ultimate
universe that are different than what
he's done in the main Marvel Universe
for example another video that we'll
have Linked In the description is a is a
video called ultimatum where basically
Magneto takes Thor's hammer and then
attacks the world it's cool like it's
it's amazing it's just one of those
coolest things but nonetheless like you
end up having basically Professor X
who's just like okay here's the thing
Magneto right like while you're so
caught up in your hubris and you're
still caught up in and whether or not
you're right and you're showing the
world that you're going to capture it
all you're not paying attention to the
bigger picture you're not looking at
what's really going on around you and
when the response back and he knows like
what the hell you're talking about
Wolverine makes his move and stabs him
in the back right now the thing about
this is that where he's able to claw and
Slash and Magneto remember like
Wolverine is a guy with adamantium on
his bones so literally Magneto just
seizes control of him like just holds
him in place and then sends a spike
flying right through him and then
incapacitates uh Wolverine in response
to that because of the fact that his
Sentinel forces have basically been
almost totally obliterated by the X-Men
there isn't much left for him to do he
makes a last-ditch effort and he
activates the nuclear bombs across the
country and literally like sends these
missiles into the air with the intention
of detonating them everywhere he can and
so what ends up happening here is
Quicksilver having had enough of his
father and basically feeling betrayed by
Magneto as well as finally coming to
terms with the fact that Magneto just
literally wiping out the entirety of the
United States is obviously not a good
idea he ends up using a super speed
whisks off the helmet of Magneto which
gives uh Professor Xavier the ability to
basically take over Magneto's mind
because remember Magneto's helmet both
in the Ultimate Universe and the main
Marvel Universe prevents Professor X
from being able to read his thoughts or
control his mind so now it's wide open
and this allows Professor X to literally
take over his head to basically shut
down his efforts to effectively launch
these nuclear missiles across the world
and then in turn he ends up killing
Magneto like encases him in a giant ball
of metal sends them flying into the air
and then the whole thing just gets
destroyed right like that's literally
all it is and so Magneto is effectively
killed here's the funny thing he's not
Magneto's not dead and there's actually
a little more going on here than that
initially meets the eye the only clue we
get as far as what's going on with the
bigger picture is you do have this sit
down that takes place between Professor
Xavier and cyclops where literally
Professor X is like okay this was all
just phase one phase two is gonna be a
lot more interesting and it is right the
X-Men Comics I mean they do go off the
rails after a little while right they do
kind of go nuts after a little while but
up until they do things are amazing
right it's one of the coolest stories to
come out of the Ultimate Universe so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace